okay we were super happy this last
basketball season mm-hmm he shoots on
teh Itza Canada
I sure was happy the Raptors won um
waves hello it is a pleasure to meet you
both
the film is incredible thank you first
we got to talk about Sterling's cover of
men's health you know it gets better
when you flip the page we've left when
we saw the campaign
ru budged you two you two I know the
shirt you know he's dressed and
everything it's like it's like it's too
much for me to believe that I actually
did it but no it's I like the cover it's
cool happy yeah I know that you said you
wanted to live until you were a hundred
yes do you want to act until you were a
hundred I liked oh damn that I you know
what I feel like it's a profession where
you never stop learning you're
constantly learning new things about
yourself and about humanity at large it
is one of those things where every time
I step into a new character I get a
chance to release a little bit of
judgment and I get a chance to love more
fully and that's all I really want to do
as a human being is just love people and
that's what acting is for me so yeah
yeah
Renee you to play a married couple in
this film who go through so much what do
you think keeps this couple together
throughout this film
oh it's beautiful that's actually the
question of the film is will they stay
together and I believe in the end we
think there's hope which is amazing I
think honestly they're together in the
beginning because they love and respect
each other and but I can't help but
think that you know he's a package deal
and the beauty of him as a father with
these two children is irresistible
to Kathryn and that's what's so
fascinating about seeing her start in
the movie so confidently running it and
and and it's so constantly running his
family and then seeing her identity
shattered when it goes so left so I love
I love the resilience of the couple I
love the fact that they she has to make
a choice to stay and I love the fact
that that just her ability to look at
him has to become about more than his
children because I don't know that she
ever had to make that decision the first
time and that was game over here yes
like it's it's like a real I do if she
stays just now changed and she and I
believe when she looks at him the last
time she might say yes to him you know
right which is I think really beautiful
yeah because there are couples that are
together for a long time and then the
kids kind of grow up and get out of the
house and they be like for sometime and
whether there's tragedy present or not
it's you have to keep choosing each
other yeah like every day I choose you
yeah I'm saying and I think you know
because we both come you know are
blessed with really beautiful marriages
it's it's a it's a path that we know
pretty well you know we're not at that
moment on the patch but uh but I think
it's that's one of the beauties of being
an actor
as we get to sometimes kind of step in
other people's shoes and learn things
before we get there fully hmm hopefully
see I love that well thank you and you
still have your wife's lipgloss on you
by that you mean his real life is real
life is really it was a pleasure thank
you guys for filming